the teenage boy is the dumbest
the dumbest thing on planet earth
look anything that laughs like this
is the dumbest [ __ ]
tell walking let me tell you how dumb
okay so my dumb [ __ ] son he had some
of his dumb friends over right
and so this is how dumb they are this is
what they laugh at
so they're in their room and i can hear
them laughing
and i hear my son dad come in here come
in here dad come in here oh go what's
going on he goes this is the funniest
thing
and i walk in and so my son and three of
his friends
shirtless by the way for whatever reason
they're always all shirtless
are standing on his bed with a cat laser
you know the thing the cats chase
around doing it around his room and one
of his dumb friends
shirtless running around like this
just slapping it like he he would put it
on his my
son would put it on another one of his
friend's chest and his friend would just
come up and go
and they would all just laugh like
[ __ ] for an hour
chasing a cat laser
i know you're buying your kids xboxes
but if it's a dude
he's too [ __ ] dumb get him a cat
laser if you get him an empty
refrigerator box even at 14
a 14 year old boy would be like there's
so much room in here
they're so [ __ ] ho ho
[Music]
foreign